this is a video that former Brazilian
president Cher bolsonaro shared on his
Facebook page earlier this week it
questions the legitimacy of the
presidential election held in October
the video was later deleted but
prosecutors say that posting such
content Justified the investigation into
whether bolsonaro incited hundreds of
his supporters who stormed Congress the
Supreme Court and government buildings
in Brasilia on January the 8th the
Supreme Court has accepted the public
Prosecutor's request to investigate
bolsonaro is now in the United States he
flew there two days before his term of
office ended on January the 1st and he
posted this picture from his hospital
bed in Florida where he was admitted
with abdominal pain
Democratic lawmakers are calling on the
U.S President Joe Biden to revoke
bolsonaro's Visa saying the U.S should
not offer Refuge to what they described
as coup plotters
outside bolsonaro's rented home in
Florida supporters are praying for him I
live here but there are people that
comes from far away to see him my sister
came from Brazil Brazil has not formally
requested bolsonaro's extradition from
the U.S he says his planning to return
to Brazil by the end of January but he's
not the only one authorities want to
speak to former security Chief Anderson
Torres was removed from his post hours
after the attacks he too is in the U.S
if next week Torres doesn't come forward
through the mechanisms of international
legal cooperation we're going to launch
the procedures for extradition since in
order for his arrest has been issued in
Brazil
more than 1500 people have been detained
after the attack on Congress but the
former president and his security Chief
are the most senior officials to face
investigation Barbara angupa altazira